Well, as always, I'm going to try this a little more simply.
Here's my lawnmower, the weight, the normal force, and the push force that comes in like this.
But that's not how I would like to draw my forces.
I'd like to draw them coming from the object, not going into it.
I'm going to draw like this and it has a value of 20 N.
I'm going to break that into a parallel component and a perpendicular one,
and then I'm going to remember that this angle here is 60°.
Well, I know that this is my equation for work and Δx, I know is 150 m.
Now, I just need to know F parallel.
Well, looking at this right triangle here, I can see F parallel at the adjacent side
and carrying out the math, I find F parallel is 10 N, multiplying this by 150 m,
I get total work of 1500 J. You got this? Very good.
Let's go back to our man, moving water along the dike to see exactly what was going on.
So in this case, the man was lifting upwards with some force,
but the direction of motion is this way.
Actually, let me just extend this arrow, so that we can see this is a right angle.
When our vectors are perpendicular in this way, no component of force,
whatever will be parallel to Δx.
In fact, whenever the force is perpendicular to the displacement of the Δx, no work is done.
One thing we haven't thought about,
is what happens when the force is in the opposite direction of the displacement?